Potentially clean your house in the future
with this robot flies concept.
And if you need a caffeine boost just let
it absorb through your skin with Sprayable
Energy.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Two baby rabbits were successfully born glowing
fluorescent green.
Researchers at the University of Hawaii injected
a naturally glowing jellyfish protein into
embryos in a pregnant rabbit - two of the
baby ended up carrying the gene.
The point is to be able to eventually make
rabbits that produce medicine in their milk
and the green glow allows researchers to see
which animals have gotten the specific gene.
Researchers at the University of Tokyo are
working on creating electronic skin.
They've been developing flexible electronic
mesh to wrap around robot hands for over a
decade and now they're bringing it to humans.
The e-skin can bend, stretch and twist and
is 10 times thinner than kitchen plastic wrap.
Right now it can be used to monitor vital
signs but eventually could be used to make
humans hyperaware or communicate simply with
our skin.
The University of Washington meanwhile have
achieved a breakthrough in direct brain-to-brain
communication.
A professor linked to another used his thoughts
to control the other's actions - making
the linked professor involuntarily move his
hand and press a space bar to play a computer
game.
And while basic hand movement is simple it
opens the door to exploring the possibilities
of sending more advanced brain signals to
each other.
Researchers at the Institute of Molecular
Biotechnology in Vienna, Austria have grown
a 3D tiny human brain.
The mini three dimensional brain models were
grown using stem cells and include parts of
the cortex, hippocampus and retinas.
And right now they're using these to study
early fetal brain development but hope to
eventually grow larger brains to provide insights
into conditions such as schizophrenia and
autism.
It turns out seahorses have squishable armor
to help protect them from being crushed by
predators and researchers at the University
of California, San Diego are building a robotic
arm from 3D printed plates mimicking this
compressible design.
So yeah.
The Uji is a new shower head that makes you
aware of how long you've been in the shower.
So far they've noticed a 12% decrease in shower
time and say that the $50 shower head will
pay for itself within 7 months.
It works by turning from green to red after
7 minutes and the hope is that people are
out of the shower by minute 8.
The Sesame Ring looks to simplify paying for
public transportation by wearing your pass
on your finger.
The rings are 3D printed and come in a variety
of colors and while it's designed to work
in Boston right now they're looking to bring
this worldwide.
Yeah, I'll be right there just let me fold
up my Korean armadillo car.
Pocket space craft is giving you the ability
to send yourself into outer space - in a way.
You can upload a picture and a personalized
message to your spacecraft that's smaller
than a CD and as thin as a piece of paper.
- which will then be launched with along with
thousands of others into space.
Check out the website for more.
Architect Shigeru Ban made a $6 Million cathedral
out of cardboard tubes.
Even though it's made out of cardboard it
is more structurally sound than the previous
cathedral that was lost in an earthquake.
The structure is called the Transitional Cathedral
and is also apparently fireproof and waterproof.
Bumpy Photo will turn standard 2D photos into
3D sculptures.
The photos can be made as small as 1" or as
large as 15" and all you have to do it upload
a picture of your choice to the website, wait
for the conversion and production and then
have it sent to your doorstep.
Finally, youtuber Vaecon used the Oculus Rift
virtual reality system, a harness to hang
15 feet off the ground and skydiving software
to create a virtual skydiving demo.
I'm gonna leave you with robots laying out
slot-car track - seriously this is awesome
- and as always - thanks for watching.